あっ
シャンプー成長したーーこちら外してそうですと言うけどね1997年の1月から出た
シャンプー ok
弊社のでこれを使って何をしようかといいますと24時間は寝ずにジャンプ読んだら
省察と言いません1000冊を読むんですけどどれくらい読めるんじゃないかなと思い
まして
国間から
ん
根津兄ジャンプを省察予防と思いますゾーンいいだろう
本が好きの皆にはた貼られどめだ20時間ディズニー
だれよぞそれじゃ
ジャンプ読み過ぎだ今なあああああ
24時間漫談嫁っていうのがすごい幸せそうに見えるんですけど持ち合わせな半姉ここ
に食い気いかれるわけですよその中でどうなのかを受けるとかもちょっと継承していき
たいと思いますそしてこんなにいいですよ
もう1997年度も僕が3歳の時ですからね
こんなになっちゃうじゃんこそは入れたなぁは集英社さんの協力のおかげです本当に
ありがとうございます
上でお知らせですなんと1,000万ダウンロード突破したアプリ少年ちゃんと+4
周年を迎えることになりましたおめでとうございます
そしてなった本日よりジャンプ+ですよね1824時間ジャンプ図形が開催中でござい
まー閉まるできょうみたいに効くのね
期間がですねチョンジンの9月の水1日の金曜日から
2018年の9月の204日のみ図3図を図客まで言ってるみたいでございます期間州
であれば少年散布の有名タイトル服72作品が無料で読めちゃいます
70自作が骨時間帯だけ読める漫画変わりますので全部読もうと思ったら24時間
かかっちゃうよという企画です
ぜひ刺激で見てくださいそそうな週刊少年ジャンプ少年団の+の例祭作品も読めます
いちご100%を彩るのはマジで暑いと思います僕の締めまあ向かいこずえちゃんです
よろしくお願いしますそしてなんと山アップダウン
外れ冊をの心がございますならずに作品中のうち6作品はなんと僕が選んだ漫画長谷見
シャツをタイムとして皆さんにお届けすることができます
カーズ中4日のその時間帯に弾み社長タイムがあるのでゴムのすすめマンガみたいよっ
て方はぜひこの時間に皆さん見てくださいと隆起するの
all
主ておきます猫のロックザリーンを決めるという意味も込めて
24時間ジャンル読みまくりますので肇社長タイプとして皆さんに秒でいただきたいと
思っておりますというわけで僕は20時間ここから動きませんどんな時も病めるときも
全部見続けばへ行っああっ
どれから読めばいいんだろうねこれから始まります朝 c ですよ
24時間ジャンプたんでー
よしさあい今回気になるのは24時間で何冊読めるのかが気になります
ただず僕の精神状態がどう変化するのかを皆さんにお伝えできればいいなと思ってい
ます
おい頃には僕とうとうのジャンプ対する知識がついてると思うんで
ぜひ皆さん期待しておいてください頑張ります
[音楽]
ん
配偶で1時間経ちましたとりあえず一冊目がマジ終わりますだよ面白いではすごい手術
して4じゃーん
これだとちょっと性など野党すぎるんでもうちょっと掲載でやっていこうと思います
やっと一撮影がヤバイ
大変時間が兵がしました一冊名読み終わってに立つ目がもう終わりそうです
やばい
面白くて黒いよねーまだ集中力が保ってるんでどんどん読んでいきたいと思いますでは
4日
なニュアンスでした
あサンジがございました weed ハーフっていうなんか
ペットの話がすごい感動的でしたね
漫画でないダンス日なら
どんどん行きましょうん
あっあった
894ずガン系いたしました
全然楽しくても読めるんですけど向けだってきましたごらんとかトイレとか
た下がっいきます
まあ気ばを終え
もうすぐ6時間が経ちます
まず読めます5時間に殺害のですおっそ
また俺様で24歩しか飲めない計算になっているまあ楽しみながら急ぎますでは
朝からノンストップで運河を呼んでおります
24時間寝ずにやるんでこの後はちょっとで目さとの戦いかなって思いますでは
google
柴尾おもろちょっとはじめスペシャルタイムの交互に早いかもしれないとまぁ企業が遅
すぎる
wh
ん
ああああああ
me
9分
[音楽]
ふーん
ふーん朝50になりましたあと2時間
なんかすごいじっとしてられないような状態に陥ってきました
だーっ
なんかは重いメンタルやばくないですかここから動いてないですからね一応自分に立つ
を
tan
[音楽]
ウーファー
フォア24時間
4 ever seen her
[音楽]
というわけで実際24時間で何冊読めたかというと結構読んだぞ
それが呼んできてくれた分
染まってもてるか船ああ腰のね俺
a
2時間でこれだけが日ましたきっ月
やっほぉニーズのなかったくらいですねペース的に言うと一時間に一冊以上読んでたん
だと思いました
いやそのじっくりやるとめちゃくちゃ一時ないじょ普通にかかると思うんで24時間で
1000冊は
うリスね今回の形状で分かったことはジャンプを1000冊読む時は1ヶ月半ぐらい
かかることが証明されました
ありがとうございました味です全然読めなかったんですけれども僕がえー何な肇社長
タイム63品8秒したいと思います読んでね放ったのこともあったんでそれも踏まえて
六崎ん
アップしていきたいと思います後期感があればジェット+るっ
無料で読めますご苦労するの漫画ぜひ皆さんちょっとパーツダウンロードして読んでみ
てください
メモさて発表しますいきます
胃腸薬はレンダー約束のネバーランド
リボ
最高パイアパンツ血界戦線会津以上がまぁ今回4月も含め僕が好きな漫画を吸ってねー
この6さあ菌がブーン見えるのがはじめちょっとタイムになりますみなさんぜひ読んで
みてください
だけ少年ジャンプ+オリジナル漫画も本数の台っていうのマンガも無料で読めます
わざわざこんな準備しなくていいねこれがもう生えてますで c レーサーの
が嫁だけであのいコインがもらえるのでぜひ新冷戦漫画家汁で声をまとめてみて
ください
そしてなんと少年ジャンプの本社の定期購読もできるらしくてそれがすごい男らしいの
で皆さんそちらも使ってみてはいかがでしょうか
動画の外アーロンたら少年ジャンプ+ダウンロードできません皆さん何浪してマンが
たくさんいてみましょう
24時間ジャンプーマジできつかったけど
ああああああ
最高でした忘れちゃ
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ